[Music]
your new show Horace and Pete yeah and
what's stunning is I've been watching
the show the people you got to be in the
program the the actors are of the
highest caliber yes right people Steve
Buscemi yeah and Edie Falco and I play
siblings and then Alan Alda plays our
uncle yeah and Jessica Lange plays our
dead father's girlfriend right I mean
they they you know she was his
girlfriend before he died yes when he
died she broke up with him yeah yeah
yeah so isn't that dark nah no she's not
dating him but yeah you know 80 Brian
yeah they're all great great terrific
actors and some great cameos from people
that I didn't expect to see and one of
the things that amazed me is that you
got Alan Alda who I for my money not
only I will say this one of the nicest
people I've ever met in show business
but also just just brilliant I loved him
in everything he does including your
show and then I'm surprised to learn
that Alan Alda was not your first choice
no no I wrote it for a Joe Pesci like
that was in my mind was Joe Pesci in a
TV show playing this guy yes we have a
VI conical Joe Pesci so I wrote it with
and I had his voice in my mind and and I
like I call my manager Dave Becky has a
special talents which he can get phone
numbers of people he can just get a
phone number you can just say to him get
me get me with his first phone number
he's Ali Lama he's batting a hundred
yeah a thousand one hundred he's batting
a thousand and one of them I said to him
Joe Pesci's phone over so he said I'll
work on it and it took a couple of weeks
but then I got it so I left a message
for him I said hi my name is louis c.k
you don't know me I'm a comedian I'm
making a TV show I want to talk to you
about it so nothing and then two weeks
later I get this call hey Louis Joe
Pesci I'm like holy [ __ ] and I was
driving so I pulled over because I was
afraid I would get in an accident from
excitement Joe Pesci
he said so I don't know who you are
never heard you really yeah he goes but
that friend of mine put some stuff in
front of me when I got your call and he
goes first of all I'm not doing your
show but he says the first thing I saw
was some stand-up I'll tell you right
now quit that cuz you're no good at that
he said yeah he said I could tell
something you're trying out it's not for
you but I saw some stuff you're acting
and it was okay but I'm not interested
in being your show I just thought I'd
give up a career school I said well let
me give me a minute to pitch you you
know to make you want to do it
I said look just let me send you the
scripts I think this you'll like this
part he said yeah but I don't want to
hurt your feelings if I don't like the
scripts and I said well yeah I mean I've
been a comedian for thirty years you
can't hurt my feelings and he goes
you're not so much a comedian as you
think you are pal he just thinks I suck
yeah because I'm second it's his
prerogative but anyway I went down to
his house and met him and he told me a
lot of really harsh things about myself
and he like he liked the writing he
turned out to be a very sweet guy and I
got to be pals with him but I don't he
won't be in the show yeah he said he
said I think the show is gonna be very
successful so I don't want to do it
here's a private guy anyone does things
that he really wants to do so he just
sign out to do it he shooter on her for
a while I got to know him which was a
great thing he's a nice guy
you